les coudes sur la victoire
sétois se voit son avance sur le quai de
la gare
une secrétaire d'état qui parle météo la
politique au beau fixe
un quart d'heure plus tard autre
ambiance plus fraîches les gilet jaune
manifestent devant la salle où la
république en marche doit se réunir
un jeune manifestant sera d'ailleurs
interpellé les militants d'extinction
rébellion sont aussi on vient ici on
pour montrer que tous les projets ne
marche pas
puisque c'est une tournée bas qui parle
des projets qui manquent en france chez
nous on a des projets qui marchent pas
comme les vais tout on remplace par du
béton l'écologie la spécialité d' eric
alauzet devant l'état-major de la
république en marche
il déroule pour ceux qui en doutaient
encore le candidat aux municipales c'est
lui ce n'est pas une écologie de façade
celle d' eric alauzet c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui on a fait le socle de son
engagement et c'est pour ça que je suis
ravie ici d'être à ses côtés dans la
salle légèrement en retrait alexandra
cordier la responsable et roem du doubs
poussé par jean louis fousseret elle
aussi vise la mairie soit elle est dans
lequel la république en marche et elle
vient avec nous soit elle se met en
dehors celle qui fera le choix et les
conséquences seront évidentes ensuite
c'est à dire quelles conséquences winter
non mais je passais tout mouvement a
décidé
alexandra cordier exclu en cas de
dissidence personne ne le dit mais
beaucoup y pensent
en cas de silence je vois pas comment on
peut rester représentants du mouvement
mais ça après c'est pas moi qui prendrai
la décision c'est simplement un point de
vue une opinion est ce qu'à terme ça
peut aller jusqu'à l'exclusion
d'alexandra quand vous savez c est
toujours été constant cette question là
jamais comme ça que j'ai envisagé les
choses quant à l'intéressée elle même
elle entretient le mystère
je vous donne rendez-vous vraiment dans
un mois mais aujourd'hui on est pas on
n'est pas sur cette initiative
on est très fiers a besoin sont
d'accueillir wind poirson fin d'après
midi inauguration du local d'eric
alauzet dans le centre ville de besançon
que besançon reste une ville progressis
une ville en marche
jean louis fousseret et alexandra
cordier ont séché l'invitation